[Music]
hello it's good to see all of you again
I expect the previous lectures of
whetted your appetite for learning more
about major transitions in evolution so
hopefully today's lecture is going to
give you the first main course of
knowledge on that topic while also
leaving you eager for more in this
lecture we're going to be diving into
the deep as part of geologic time and
we're going to discuss the first and the
longest of the major transitions this is
the evolution of simple prokaryotic
cells into more complex eukaryotic cells
now I'm in awe of this topic first
because of the vast amounts of time that
are needed to be considered also it
means all subsequent evolutionary
transitions everything we're going to
discuss in this course I really want to
emphasize this stems from this one
transition as you recall relative age
dating is discerned by noting how
fossils have a definite order in the
geologic record also known as biological
succession this was known before
evolutionary theory had developed and
it's still used by geologists today
absolute age dating involves the use of
radiometric techniques such as ratios of
parent daughter isotope pairs to supply
definite dates for rocks and fossils
that might be associated with these
rocks using these two tools along with a
firm understanding of geologic processes
and Earth history we can reliably figure
out when these evolutionary transitions
happened even one that looks at life
from one two or even three billion years
ago with these principles in mind we're
now nearly ready to go back into deep
time or what we informally call the
Precambrian the Precambrian is a general
term used by geologists and
paleontologists referring to all
geologic time before the Cambrian period
anything more than five hundred and
forty three million years ago put
another way the Precambrian encompasses
both the Archaean and the proterozoic
eon with the Archaean Eon corresponding
roughly to the very earliest life on
Earth during 4.0 to 2.5 billion years
ago and the proterozoic eon that follows
from 2.5 billion
543 million years ago a span of almost 2
billion years corresponding very roughly
to the transition we'll be discussing
today now I say very roughly because the
boundaries for the eons were defined
long before many of the scientific
results we'll be discussing today now
overall the Precambrian represents
almost 90% of Earth history yet only the
first two evolutionary transitions we
cover in this course are from that time
span all other transitions occurred
during the remaining 10% of geologic
time so if we organize this course so
that each lecture represented equal
amounts of geologic time it would come
out to about 200 million years per
lecture we would arrive at the first
evidence of life of any sort here in
lecture 3 well so far so good
but we wouldn't begin discussed - the
first major transition within life which
is our actual subject today until
lecture 9 or so the earliest evidence
for that second major transition that
would be about lecture 13 probably even
more surprising we wouldn't even get to
the evolution of dinosaurs until the
start of the very last lecture Oh in the
evolution of humans that be covered in
the last 45 seconds of that last lecture
so this sort of scaling hopefully puts
geologic time in perspective for you and
it certainly does for me now as for the
origins of life that's really a
different subject for another course
let's just point out that all of life
known on earth today is based on the
same macro molecular building blocks of
genes and proteins this familiar fact
gives new meaning to an observation by
Charles Darwin he pointed out that
nature produces huge variety but isn't
so good at inventing anything new what
that means is a small set of basic forms
can recombine to produce the almost
endless variety we see throughout the
history of evolution so life begins with
prokaryotic cells or simply prokaryotes
which are still very important today and
include two groups bacteria and archaea
a bacteria we all know about because
these microbes affect human health and
we're conscious of the effects bacteria
have in our daily lives giving us
reasons to wash our hands disinfect
wounds or use antibiotics the other
group of a prokaryotes parkia may not be
so familiar to many of you which that's
okay because it was unknown to science
until 1977 and this oversight was
understandable because these
single-celled organisms are
superficially similar to bacteria in
fact some people have even referred to
them as archaea bacteria but this is a
little misleading because they most
definitely are not bacteria they differ
from bacteria by having some unique
metabolisms and biochemical traits that
they actually share with eukaryotes
none of these are known as pathogens and
some function is mutualist in which they
live symbiotically with another organism
in fact you may have some archaeans
living in your gastrointestinal tract
right now named matheno bravo factor or
matheno Sphero these aid in digestion
and as you can tell from their names
they produce methane as a metabolic
by-product now incidentally our cans are
not to be confused with the Archaean Eon
although there certainly were Parthians
in the archaea which does get confusing
if I say it that way so remind me not to
do that again
well we and every other eukaryotic
organism would have found the early ark
in a very unpleasant environment with
high temperatures low oxygen high
methane which is partly from precarious
but also from volcanoes all punctuated
by frequent meteor showers oh well
anyway we'll talk more about bacteria
and archaea and later but for now know
that prokaryotes have the following
features they're small size they don't
have a nucleus or a nuclear envelope the
chromosomes instead are scattered
throughout the cell there aren't any
organelles with membranes and they're
typically expressed as one celled life
in other words they don't organize into
multicellular organisms and they have
asexual reproduction
now the transition to eukaryotic cells
makes possible all life other than
bacteria in archaeans so this includes
algae both single-celled and
multi-celled and all other plants
protists tens which are single-celled
organ
zones that are closer to animals such as
a me Bay and foraminifera and of course
animals in contrast to prokaryotic cells
eukaryotic cells have the following
trees their larger size they have a
definite nucleus with a nuclear envelope
the chromosomes are all enclosed in one
place they have complex organelles such
as mitochondria and chloroplasts and
they reproduce sexually now because of
their primitive traits in smaller sizes
prokaryotic cells clearly had to have
evolved into larger and more complex
ProCare eukaryotic cells at some time in
the geologic past but before we talk
more about that evolutionary transition
let's examine how uniformitarianism
helped us to better understand what life
was like a few billion years before
animals had evolved since the first half
of the 19th century geologists and
paleontologists had known about some
intriguing fossils from the Precambrian
called stromatolites stromatolites which
are these layered structures and
sedimentary rocks are often expressed as
prominent dome-like or mound like
features in Precambrian rocks scientists
hypothesize that stromatolites were made
by colonies of cyanobacteria which can
be either photosynthetic bacteria or
they could have been from single-celled
algae and these were preserved as trace
fossils of those colonies because these
bacterial or algal colonies grew on
muddy or sandy surfaces in shallow
marine environments and they form sticky
mats that collected suspended sediment
on these mats think of flypaper but
substitute the Flies with sediment okay
some of these colonies then show up in
rocks from about 3.5 billion years ago
during the Archaean Eon and some of them
became huge during the proterozoic eon
from about 2.5 billion years ago so does
this mean that eukaryotes appear 3.5
billion years ago no probably not
we think that's from analytes began
before the evolution of eukaryotic cells
such as algae
and they actually span the transition
the Archaean stromatolite seem to have
been made only by cyanobacteria whereas
the Proterozoic stromatolites were made
by algae or a combination of algae and
cyanobacteria now stromatolites were
fairly common in shallow marine
environments for almost 3 billion years
but they mostly disappear from
sedimentary rocks made from about 545
million years ago which is also the
beginning of the phanerozoic eon hmm
this is also when we see a rapid
increase in the body and trace fossils
of animals so paleontologists figured
that these inverse relationships between
stromatolites and animals came about
because some marine animals ancestors to
say snails and other molluscan had
evolved to graze on these mats thus
causing their demise well the problem
with this idea was that not everyone
agreed on the origin of stromatolite
says mats of cyanobacteria or algae
some scientists even proposed
geochemical origins from a delights that
were completely unrelated to life but
without any modern examples to compare
to the fossil record this was a
disagreement that was tough to resolve
so what helped to change our views of
stromatolites and hence life during the
Archaean in the Proterozoic was the
discovery of modern stromatolites as
so-called living fossils these live
stromatolites were found in 1956 in and
along the coast of western australia in
a place called Shark Bay and they are
absolutely beautiful examples of
stromatolites just as paleontologists
had predicted they were colonies of
cyanobacteria that had trapped and bound
sediment onto sticky mats but how did
they escape destruction from hungry
grazing animals such as modern marine
snails
well these stromatolites live in a
lagoon with very high salt content and
that's called hyper sailing these
conditions exclude animals that normally
would eat this from
lights since then scientists have found
more modern stromatolites in other parts
of the world such as in the Bahamas Abu
Dhabi and other places that have the
right conditions for excluding animals
that normally would eat them I've
personally seen stromatolite saying
hyper saline lakes in the Bahamas and I
am just thrilled to know these modern
examples are still around to help us
understand these stromatolites from the
ancient past so let's look at some
reasons why precarious though or
consider the most primitive examples of
life well first of all prokaryotes are
only organized the only organisms we see
today that can live in extreme
environments with very hot very cold or
anoxic blow oxygen conditions this hints
at their long history of adapting to
drastically changing environments
prokaryotes are also very simple
compared to eukaryotic cells in their
organization of genetic material also
their lack of organelles and a sexual
reproduction evolutionary biologists
regard these as very basic traits for
life while more complex forms took more
time to evolve so we might think about
for instance the deep sea floor where we
have hydrothermal vents and that's a
place where these bacteria could evolve
we also have prokaryotes that are in
lakes hyper saline and very hot
hydrothermal pools in Yellowstone
National Park these are also examples of
extreme environments where these
organisms thrive and live today all
beside stromatolites what's the fossil
record for prokaryotes for these we can
look to three lines of evidence chemical
fossils body fossils and trace fossils
now chemical fossils as you recall from
the previous lecture are elements or
compounds in rocks found in certain
amounts or combinations that indicate
the former presence of life these are
very simply called biomarkers now for
early life one of these biomarkers is
provided by stable carbon isotope ratios
you've probably heard that carbon
isotopes are used for radiometric age
dating
but that's different carbon dating looks
at the ratio of an unstable isotope the
parent element carbon-14 to a stable
isotope or the daughter element which is
nitrogen 14 on the other hand carbon has
two stable isotopes that don't decay
carbon-12 and carbon-13 carbon 12s by
far the more abundant of the two making
up about 99% of all carbon atoms but
carbon 13 is abundant enough that modern
instruments can easily detect it and
calculate how does it vary with relation
to carbon-12 and of given rock sample
now carbon-14 we don't even worry about
that in Precambrian rocks because it has
such a short half-life only about 5,700
years so it's going to be absent for
many rocks and long decayed and altered
into its daughter element nitrogen 14
any rocks that come from the Precambrian
so what we have observed about life and
stable carbon isotopes is that living
things tend to concentrate carbon-12
relative to carbon 13 this means that
the ratio should differ noticeably from
a ratio of these two isotopes in the
absence of life so this signature of
life shows up distinctly in the ratio
between the two isotopes and certain
ratios are only caused by life now
people who study the chemical
compositions of rocks known simply as
geochemists are the ones we turn to
whenever we're trying to figure out
these ratios now since carbons stable
carbon isotope ratios indicate the
earliest evidence of life well we've
looked for then rocks from Greenland and
these date to about 3.7 billion years
ago and we have that evidence
unfortunately we don't have any we don't
have any really good way of knowing
exactly what types of prokaryotes were
responsible for this geo chemical
signature but we're pretty sure that
prokaryotes were responsible for these
biomarkers now in terms of how life
formed might've derived energy we're
also pretty sure that the first life
forms were very likely anaerobic
heterotrophs in other words they gained
their food from outside sources of just
like modern archaeans autotrophs evolve
later
because from analytes are formed by the
upward growth of cyanobacteria or
single-celled algae their presence in
our Qian age rocks implies that
prokaryotes had already evolved from
anaerobic heterotrophs to autotrophs
moreover some autotrophs had probably
evolved to have chloroplasts
chloroplasts or organelles that gather
sunlight and use it to make their own
food through photosynthesis just like
plants and algae do today these types of
autotrophs are norm no more specifically
as photoautotrophs
now body fossils of probable prokaryotic
cells are younger than the chemical
fossils but they're still pretty old
about 3.4 to 3.2 billion years ago these
fossils have small sizes no nuclei and
they're similar in their forms to modern
prokaryotes these fossils are preserved
in rocks in both South Africa and
Australia the rocks are composed of
church and church wonderful because it's
a silicon dioxide and it's very good for
preserving fossils over long periods of
geologic time now trace fossils of
prokaryotes we already mentioned these
stromatolites and they're even older
than the body fossils stromatolites have
been found in rocks from 3.5 billion
years ago in Australia although they're
much more common in Proterozoic rocks
some of these stromatolites were so big
they actually formed the first known
reefs during the Archean and the
Proterozoic again the later
stromatolites of the Proterozoic may
have been incorporating algae that marks
the transition to eukaryotes now another
type of trace fossil caused by
prokaryotes are etching zin minerals
these are sometimes called bio
alterations in which the microbes
actually altered the minerals these
leave distinctive marks that match those
seen in modern prokaryotes the oldest
known bio alterations are etching seen
and formerly volcanic rocks of South
Africa these are dated as 3.5 billion
years so when do you carry otic cells
show up in the fossil record it's a
little tough to tell especially because
we're looking so far back
and time also because of plate tectonics
weathering and other earth processes
that tend to recycle elements at and
near the Earth's surface Precambrian
fossils are the least likely to be
preserved but we know that this fossil
evidence should be in sedimentary rocks
that formed in aquatic environments such
as marine environments furthermore we
can predict the ages of the rocks based
on what we already know about
prokaryotic fossils as well as through
molecular clocks now based on molecular
clocks scientists have calculated dates
for the probable evolutionary divergence
between prokaryotes and eukaryotes these
estimates though are wildly varied they
ranged from about 3.9 to 2.2 billion
years ago
so with 1.7 billion years to play with
how to narrow this down well for one
most evolutionary biologists think this
divergence probably happened later
rather than sooner perhaps close to 2.2
billion years ago
thus fossils are very helpful for better
pinpointing when this divergence
happened although the fossil record for
the oldest eukaryotes isn't great we do
have chemical fossils body fossils and
possibly trace fossils of them for
chemical fossils biomarkers known as
turnings are in rocks from 2.7 billion
years ago turnings are only found in
eukaryotes so we can be relatively sure
these compounds indicate either a
presence of eukaryotes or their
immediate ancestors body fossils of
probable eukaryotes include some fossil
algae that are in rocks from 2.1 billion
years ago now remember algae or
eukaryotes oh and accurate arcs which
are these organic wall micro fossils
these show up in rocks from about 1.7
billion years ago
now although aquapark is kind of a
catch-all term for the remains of the
oldest organisms paleontologists have
looked at they haven't precisely
identified them so these so called aqua
tarts though they do bear some
resemblance to modern eukaryotic cells
now rocks from northern Australia also
contains some eukaryotic fossils that
date from about 1.5 billion years ago so
how did these eukaryotes and prokaryotes
come together and how is there some sort
of evolution than if you carry us out of
those well compared to prokaryotes
eukaryotes have a greater genetic
similarity to parkia rather than
bacteria thus these two groups
eukaryotes and archaeans probably shared
a common ancestor now oddly enough
though some of the eukaryotes also have
traits that are shared with bacteria so
one mode for the evolution of eukaryotes
though is endosymbiosis endosymbiosis
literally means living together within
which in this instance refers to
multiple prokaryotic cells fusing to
form eukaryotic cells perhaps even
combining a bacterium and an Archaean
now this scenario some smaller
prokaryotic cells developed into
mitochondria and chloroplasts and other
specialized organelles after being
engulfed by larger prokaryotic cells now
this process would have been favorably
selected if both prokaryotes benefited
from the symbiosis now an alternative
hypothesis is that both archaeans
and eukaryotes descended separately from
bacterial ancestors well so far though
there's less evidence supporting this
hypothesis than fir endosymbiosis
another problem is it also requires a
few more steps than endosymbiosis so it
goes against a basic perspective that we
evolutionary scientists like to use
whenever we assess an evolutionary
scenario and this principle is called
parsimony in other words whatever
scenario requires the fewest steps is
more likely to be the correct one so
what sort of selection pressures would
have led to endosymbiosis well that's a
very good question
eukaryotes have lower metabolic rates
than prokaryotes and that's a function
of their lesser surface area volume
ratios so their early evolution probably
happened in environments that favor
organisms with lower energy needs or
organisms with some sort of novel means
for acquiring energy such as enhanced
photosynthesis or consuming new complex
molecules that would be in heterotrophs
now I mention sexual reproduction
earlier too and let's think about that
with regard to the evolution of
eukaryotes prokaryotes use asexual means
for reproduction such as binary fission
or gene transfer
now eukaryotes by contrast they began
with mitosis that's a form of cell
division in which chromosomes containing
DNA are duplicated from parent cell into
two daughter cells also having identical
number of chromosomes this full
complement of chromosomes is called
diploid whereas half that number is
happily at some point perhaps about 1.5
billion years ago meiosis also evolved
in eukaryotic cells this is a form of
cell division in which only half of the
chromosomes are incorporated into new
haploid cells how meiosis began is one
of the remaining mysteries of evolution
but greater genetic variability in
eukaryotes certainly enabled these
organisms to better adapt to changing
environments now as you probably know
especially if you yourself have
reproduced these haploid cells are also
called gametes and by convention they're
divided into male and female gametes no
I'm not gonna go any further with that
explanation but as many of you probably
already learned this outside of this
course anyway the development of sexual
reproduction certainly would have
accelerated evolution in eukaryotes
through its effect on genetic variety
through sexual recombination think about
how genes are shuffled more readily by
sex in which separate haploid sets of
genes from male and female parents they
make these new combinations that never
would have happened through binary
fission mutations gene exchanges or all
of these other mechanisms for producing
genetic variety remember one of Darwin's
original print
balls of natural selection was that
great variety existed within species
that allowed for selection of certain
favorable traits and although Darwin
didn't know about the source of that
variation genes in other words he did
recognize that sexual reproduction was
responsible for bringing out variations
rapidly this was especially evident in
selective breeding of say domestic
animals or special breeds of plants
moreover an exchange of genetic material
might have also helped to remedy any
errors in the copying of DNA or it
prevented errors from occurring in the
first place
this would have been an immediate
advantage for the first organisms making
that transition to meiosis the
chromosomes of meiosis also may have
started out as a way to suppress gene
recombination so with the evolution of
eukaryotes came the evolution of sex
which hmm I suppose many people consider
that as a major transition in evolution
in and of itself well how did this
evolution of eukaryotes from prokaryotes
change the world literally other than
through the origin of sex
well we could think about cyanobacteria
also known as blue-green algae
evolving followed by the first red algae
about 1.2 billion years ago and green
algae about 750 million years ago how
these photosynthesizers diversified and
proliferated throughout the world's
oceans think about how this increase in
algal abundance whether they were
single-celled whether they were
multicellular caused an increase in
oxygen content of the oceans and
atmosphere this is from photosynthesis
this increase in oxygen also likely
caused microvilli extinction event
because anaerobic bacteria to them
oxygen is poison say well they would
have been poisoned by the oxygen being
intruded into their formerly safe
environments the earliest fungi we've
all by about 1.5 billion years ago
apparently with flagella which made them
closer to animals than play
these new eukaryotes filled a niche as
decomposers in marine environments and
later on they would fill in that same
sort of rolled in terrestrial
environments once life started going on
to land and as with the transition from
single cell to multicellular algae
eukaryotic cells capable of movement
increasingly organized into
multicellular colonies and they even
evolved into multicellular organisms
that were moving around in the later
part of the Proterozoic about 600
million years ago these were the
earliest animals and of course we all
know how animals have changed the world
in many ways so our next lecture is
going to jump far forward in time and
we're going to look at a second major
transition from single-celled eukaryotes
that were capable of movement which are
called protozoans into multi-celled
organisms we call metazoans in other
words the evolution of the first animals
and how those animals represented a
major transition in the evolution of
eukaryotes see you then
[Music]
[Music]